the headline should just say Invasion at
the border well of course they won't who
who wrote this
isuk here you go they call him the
people Smuggler oh that sounds like a
super villain name the people Smuggler
was filmed by Texas department of safety
drone on Wednesday near Eagle Pass this
is Wednesday take this photo post it on
Twitter and say Invasion okay spare me
these dudes are coming with rifles and
our our guys aren't even allowed to
defend this country from armed people
wow again why does this happen to be a
law I just don't get this I I I mean I'm
I'm glad it is if no one has thought
that this is something that's necessary
why do we have a border if we're not
trying to stop people who are entering
armed who are trying to enter illegally
wall armed like again what are we doing
team well what are we doing s why are
these Governors sending the national
guard down there if they AR aren't I
didn't know they're not allowed
toos put out their arms and be like go
back